jake paul is a wild [ __ ] boy if  you're just an average like  run-of-the-mill fighter would you fight  jake knowing what you and your family is  going to have to go through and imagine  you're a girl he's posting pictures and  [ __ ] picture eugene now your girl got to  talk to her friends about it you got to  get a company to like go through your  whole history like on some presidential  [ __ ] wipe everything clean yeah get all  your family members get all this [ __ ]  off one more thing about jake why do you  think he beats connor in boxing i think  it's literally just he's good at boxing  and he has an immense size advantage yes  i'm almost not interested in jake  fighting him just strict boxing because  i think it'll be too easy for jake is  that crazy